are you and AOC secretly
friends or bigger question do you wish
you and her and just people in general
of all political Persuasions to would
talk more with empathy and maybe have a
little bit more fun and Good Vibes and
humor on
online um I'm always in favor of humor
that's why we have funny mode but Good
Vibes camaraderie humor you know like uh
like friendship yeah I don't well I you
know I I don't know aocf you know was um
I've only been at one I was at the the
Met wo when she was when she attended um
and she she was wearing this dress uh
but I can only see one side of it so it
it it looked like eat the itch but I I
don't know what the rest of it said yeah
yeah something not
sure something about the itch eat the
itch I think we should have a language
model
complete what are the possible ways to
complete that sentence and so I guess
that uh that didn't work out well well
there's still hope I'm I root for
friendship sure sounds good more car
listic